gary delebate says he doesn't want to
come back into the city for work but
then he goes to broadway and watches
bruce springsteen and he's sitting in a
crowded theater these things yeah he's
been to a concert he's been he just
doesn't want to go to work that's where
he does yeah exactly you know what he
just he
he went to the theater and he didn't
even wear a mask he just sat there
without his mask on he wore it in and
then he took his mask no
you know what it is he told a lot of
people he goes i like working from home
so much more because i don't have jason
looking at me eating my locks and eating
my pretzels
plantains my plantain chips and no one's
commenting on me and knowing that i'm
like dude you missed the point of your
value on this show
you're useless to me sitting in your
house if you're reading
somebody in there watching you
yeah you're the guy we goof on
i didn't know that was that was my only
value no you do a lot of things but
those things other people could do
on air value
your on-air value is what gives you your
value why do you prefer working i'm i'm
going to make you go back into the city
and work because you're willing to go to
broadway and watch bruce springsteen
without a mask on so what are you afraid
to go i'm one i didn't say i was afraid
i'm willing to go back to work i just
say i like not commuting i enjoy
commuting no one can argue
but yeah i also like not having jason
outside my office watching me eat as
well that's a that's a perk i don't know
how many hours a day he's actually
working you know
here's the thing this is why you're
sitting are you about this you don't
[ __ ] want any hours anybody else a
lot dude i work
what do you mean no i only wanted to
worry about you i know you're my father
worry about others listen no why do i
i'm the boss i don't have to worry about
it you're the one who pops in my mind i
go i wonder what gary's doing
i work plenty [ __ ] hard i know just
take it easy
it's just fun to watch you at work
like to me one of the best showments was
gary napping catching him napping during
the show that kind of magic he can't get
back i want him back where i can see him
if we had been working from home
maybe we would never have caught that
yeah because then if gary was napping
we'd go hey where's gary yeah you get
back on you go i don't know my zoom went
out
for 10 minutes
i feel bad about this but i just always
suspect that gary's having too much free
time i i want him working more
gary you know what it is gary like
reveals himself he told everyone he
played a lot of pickleball this summer i
don't know what pickleball is
but he shouldn't tell people he's
playing a lot of pickleball
hold on i literally only played it on
vacation we'll see this is the thing i
think
that gary enjoys life this bothers you
yeah
it kind of does
because gary got a tesla over the summer
he did last year we talked about it for
a [ __ ] hour yeah we talked about it
but he but like in his downtime i don't
remember your cars
gary gary's excited because he figured
out how to make the car horn you know
the actual horn you honk he he figured
out how to make it fart
[Music]
it's true how do you do that
and i was just like like he shouldn't
have time for that it we have a busy
career busy show it annoys me he just
got to keep that quiet i don't yeah but
howard everybody has a life outside of
the show
mine seems to be the only one you're
interested in everyone has a life
outside of the show i'm interested in
he's always been interested in you no
matter how many people join the staff
he's interested in you i i'm willing to
abdicate my interest to them you can you
can
yeah i don't know you you get the honor
you know what makes it more interesting
is you don't want this attention
you